at the moment a lot of our leaders are
not being brave they're allowing the mob
to run rampant tonight there is new
leaked audio from Chicago that shows
exactly what was going on behind the
scenes it's remarkable and not
surprisingly our chief breaking news
correspondent trace Gallagher has it all
on tape Tracy hi Tucker this was a
conference call on May Sunday May 31st
to talk about Chicago's response to the
widespread looting on the call were
mayor Lori Lightfoot and all 50 Chicago
aldermen and alder women including
Alderman Raymond Lopez one of the
mayor's harshest critics now for context
on the day of the conference call
Chicago had 699 arrests mostly looters a
hundred thirty two officers were injured
there were 48 shootings 17 homicides and
Alderman Lopez accused the mayor of
being underprepared as the looting
spread saying his ward had become a
virtual war zone listen half our
neighborhoods are already obliterated
it's too late we have to come up with a
better plan because once my fear is once
what they're done looting and rioting
and whatever is gonna happen tonight god
help us what happens when they start
going after residents going into the
neighborhoods once they start trying to
break down people's doors where they
think they got something there you know
we know that people are here to
antagonize an insight and you've got
them all pumped tonight today they're
not gonna go to bed at 8 o'clock they're
gonna turn their focus in the
neighborhoods I've got gangbangers with
ak-47s walking around right now just
waiting to settle some scores what are
we gonna do it and the alderman wasn't
exaggerating his ward to Walgreens were
burned down along with restaurants shops
and an entire strip mall but when Lopez
finished speaking
mayor Lightfoot refused to respond so
Alderman Lopez demanded that she respond
finally she did watch
that I can say to you maybe you should
come out of seeing what's going on
stupidest thing I understand you want
the pre you need to check your attitude
that you need to turn the other alderman
jumped in to calm things down but
alderman Lopez than the mayor weren't
the only ones trading profanities
another altar woman was heard saying
this is a total blank show and the mayor
added that she'd never seen blank like
this before one alderman finally spoke
up saying many people in the city were
listening to the call including children
Tucker
amazing amazing tape trace caliber
thanks so much for that